ein kleiner junge sechs jahre alt in
einem der vororte von kiew neben dem
grab seiner mama mit pflastersteinen
eingefasst und das diesen kinderaugen
bespricht unendliche trauer verwirrung
schmerz diese augen haben dinge gesehen
die kein kind jemals sehen sollte dieses
kind hat erlebt was kein kind jemals
erleben sollte so ein grauen ein grauen
wie dieses grauen hier
wir zeigen ihnen was die kinder erleben
in diesem krieg
[Musik]
das erleben die kinder in diesem krieg
diesen horror in den bunkern die sirenen
die einschläge die todesangst
und die vororte in nordwesten von kiew
jetzt da die russischen truppen dort
zurückgedrängt sind dort wird jetzt ein
ausmass unvorstellbarer brutalität klar
kriegsverbrechen zivilisten
abgeschlachtet noch mehr tote als in
butter könnte es dort geben warnt
präsident selensky paul ronzheimer hat
die kleinstadt 80 kilometer nördlich von
kiew besucht
ähnlich wie in butter ist von der stadt
bianca nicht mehr viel übrig überall ein
bild der verwüstung die russischen
truppen haben sich zurückgezogen was
bleibt das chaos und die straße auf der
build vize paul ronzheimer mit seinem
team entlangfährt offenbart nur eines
hoffnungslosigkeit
die zerstörung die russische truppen in
den orten rund um kirch hinterlassen
haben ist überall zu sehen auch hier gab
es heftigen artilleriebeschuss in dieser
straße in der wir sind fast alle häuser
zerstört hier hinter mir dieses gebäude
wurde von der russischen armee als
kommandostelle benutzt man sieht dass v
das überall nicht nur an panzern und
transportfahrzeugen gemalt ist sondern
auch hier an dieser wand und die russen
die sich hier zurückgezogen haben von
denen sagen uns die ukraine das sie
brutal vorgegangen sind unser team
trifft hanna eine 74-jährige bewohnerin
biancas die über plünderungen und gewalt
der russischen soldaten spricht
[Musik]
sie sind in jedes haus gekommen sie
suchten und nahmen was sie konnten gold
kleider fernseher elektrogeräte sogar
die unterwäsche haben sie gestohlen
anders als in butter liegen nicht in
borodjanka keine leichen auf der straße
doch unsere augenzeugin weiß von
brutalen gewalt exzessen der putin
truppen zu berichten
sie haben männer festgenommen sie haben
sie nahe der kirche auf pellets ihn
zusammengeschlagen und andere dinge über
dich ausruhen können
und am ende bricht es aus hannah doch
heraus sie ist verzweifelt weil die
russischen truppen ihre schwester
ermordet haben
in chamonix sven schwester wollte in ihr
haus fleisch schulen da die elektrizität
banker in horde rüstung haben von hilfen
und hat sie rücklings erschossen
borodjanka butscher in allen orten rund
um kiew ähneln sich die bilder und das
ausmaß an plünderungen gewalt an der
zivilbevölkerung und verwüstung ihrer
wohnungen wird erst nach dem rückzug von
putins soldaten sichtbar
und paul ronzheimer ist jetzt zurück in
der kriegs hauptstadt in kiew und uns
jetzt zugeschaltet paul deine
beobachtungen die erlebnisse dort in
borodjanka sie ähneln roger ist zu
befürchten dass wir immer mehr solche
bilder jetzt aus den vororten rund um
kiew bekommen immer mehr
kriegsverbrechen da aufgedeckt werden
und vor allem auch dass sie immer mehr
begangen werden
was gibts ja ich bin wirklich geschockt
nachdem wir dort das foto bianca
zurückgekommen sind denn man muss das so
klar sagen butscher ist kein einzelfall
weiß nicht ein ort an dem irgendwelche
truppen ausgerastet sind und dann leute
erschossen habe nein man sieht das
system dahinter und das sieht man dort
in borodjanka wir haben gerade hanna
gehört wie sie darüber berichtet hat was
ihr passiert ist was ihrer schwester
passiert ist die nahrung holen wollte
und dann auf der straße ermordet wurde
und die männer die dort immer noch
vermisst sind denn eins muss man sagen
patricia viele derjenigen der opfer die
meisten davon männer die kennen wir noch
nicht viele von denen sind nicht
aufgefunden worden die leichen
vielleicht irgendwo verscharrt oder sie
sind gekidnappt worden und mitgenommen
worden auch das ist möglich also der
horror der stunde für stunde weiter
deutlich wird ist wirklich extrem
es ist eine ganz klare strategie putins
ist seine strategie genau diese bilder
zu produzieren genau das mit den
zivilisten der ukraine zu machen
wladimir putin hatte in den vergangenen
kriegen ähnliches tun lassen und
anordnen lassen wir wissen was in syrien
passiert ist und wir wissen auch was
2014 drei 2014 eben in der ost ukraine
passiert ist also diese verfolgung von
zivilisten die gehört zum
taktik zur strategie der russischen
armee und die bilder dieses deutet
rutscher gegeben hat die bilder die wir
aus produktions- und anderen orten hören
patricia wir hören immer wieder dass es
nicht nur weit an männern gegeben hat
sondern auch vergewaltigung von frauen
wir hören davon dass sogar kinder
misshandelt worden sein sollen all das
wird weiter zu überprüfen sein wir
müssen dabei vorsichtig sein wir müssen
die augenzeugen befragen und so viele
berichte wie nur irgendwie möglich
h die öffentlichkeit bringen aber es ist
davon auszugehen dass das eine strategie
ist um angst zu machen und panik zu
schüren und denjenigen die jetzt im
osten sind momentan die zivilisten die
dort im osten die bomben hören die sie
reden hören der russischen armee die
dort vor rückt die versuchen wird städte
wie hp und deshalb nie probleme andere
anzugreifen
diesen zivilisten zu zeigen schaut euch
das an das kann mit euch passieren